Film Courage: Can you describe
your typical writing day?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer:
Yes, so I said that I get
a lot of good stuff down earlier. My brain just is
more lucid I think maybe because I’m coming off of
sleep. So 6:00, 7:00 to 9:00 a.m is where I
think I write my best. That's me personally and
I would just tackle that
and try to write some days.
I could get four pages, some days I’ll get
half a page but when I’m finishing up a script
I will write until two or three from that moment.
So I try to get a good eight hours. Sometimes I’ll
stare at the page or I’m researching or talking
things out or writing out but when I'm finished
working on a script I try to do that a good
amount like a good steady amount each day.
The rewrites, when I'm doing
rewrites so after just recently
we just did a read through so we'll have it read
through see how it sounds because sometimes when
you read a script you read it faster or slower
so when you have someone who just reads it
out you could get a better time if it's the scenes
too long if everyone's tweeting their thumb and
going like hey let's wrap this up that's when we
you could tell we want to cut up more and make it
faster so we'll do a read through and then we'll
have notes and then I'll go through wake up and
send some emails but then I'll go through the
notes and and and knock knock it out and go hey
this we need to add a little more humor here or
hey we got to do this or cut this out or this is a
three-page scene we need to trim it down so I
would work those angles so again the earlier
the better for me so I could it doesn't seem
like my brain works a little bit better that
that way when you do the read through or you
have someone else do it are they reading with
no emotion yeah they're just reading it
through so they don't have to act it out
they could just read scene headings seeing this
and sometimes they they'll get into an act but
they don't have to be it doesn't have to be like
a table root of everything but just go interior
Jacob's kitchen so-and-so comes in then and
they're they'll just read it normal yeah so
so we could see the pacing and then if there's
a issue where they want to go it's like hey
does he really have does he really say yes ma'am
right now he said it three yes ma'am three three
three pages ago or something I don't think he's
going say yes ma'am now so you could really
kind of work on dialogue too and that it just
sounds a little bit off or forced so it every
everyone would have like an idea and me
as a writer I'll take the notes and go and
that helps that helps because when you
when you guys are reading in your head
sometimes you get stuck so it's nice to kind of
hear it hear the words out it doesn't have to
be acted out but but that gives you a better time
frame so I recommend that if you get even a friend
after you finish something having to read through
it took the last three three took us about
we started 11 and finished it at like four because
you're going through each word each page each word
we have a stop and you go oh what do you think
about that things like that so that really helped
there's a new new job description
in the pandemic yeah have a job as a
reader yeah just read it through on zoom or
something yeah yeah absolutely nice because
it's better to have someone versus a writer
read it or director so you could sit there have
your team of collaborators a producer director
whoever and so they could hear it hear it out
once you start writing a screenplay how often do
you write how often do you go to write it so page
one of something you're getting up at six in the
morning maybe you're excited and then maybe you're
stopping at nine a.m depending on your schedule
and then how often are you going back to it
during the day during the course of however long
it takes you to finish so whether it's a year
10 years I just did I just finished
one it took me about four months and I
spent every day pretty much at it for about
average of like four to five hours a day on it so
that one yeah so it depends like I said
the always to perla look how long it took
but now as you get better and you're
more confident of of of what you want
and the structure of the scenes and things
like that and I had in my head of like
what stephen king always says of like you don't
wait for inspiration you just get to work so even
if I'm staring at the page or something on zone
in I'm i'm focusing on it so I i wanted to kind of
just keep chiseling it and and sometimes you get
great breakthroughs and you'll write a good amount
but it's it's it's different for each one for
the last couple ones I'll be disciplined on
that like I just try to treat myself like a
like an athlete if I had to go do this for if
in a day what would so and so I hear let's say
like I just read something it was just on jimmy
butler from miami he gets he said he was up
at 3 or 4 a.m practicing or something like
that so I want I wanted to implement those
kind of like practices they all say like
I i try to do things that that that you don't
want to do because they're usually good for you
and then so it's like I don't want to wake up
every day and do this but but if you love it
and if you're challenged by it it's it's not that
painful so I'm fortunate to kind of go oh awesome
i'm going work on this meanwhile we're also
trying to run commercials and things like that so
you have to balance kind of different things and
stuff and and doing that and you might not have
certain weeks where you can but I'll try to at
least slide something in maybe in it maybe it's
2 am to 4 afterwards but at least I'll try
to put the hours in for writing yeah well
so you have writings occasionally at 2 a.m yeah
sometimes yeah sometimes yeah because you're like
you're just so you're just so kind of
addicted to it because like you're in the cup
if you're just in the cusp of breaking through
the scene and just get it out and then you can
come back later and elevate it and and
just and texturize it and do this but
but you're in a roll and like if you keep getting
rolls then you'll get to that 90 page 100 page and
you're like ah I finished and let it sit and
now you could work on the rewrite afterwards.
Question For The Viewers: Do you write for
ore than 3 hours on a typical writing day?